a father is sentenced for killing his
son we thank you for joining us here at
five o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus our camera was the only one
in the courtroom as the murderer learned
his fate this is a story 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been
closely following she has the very
latest from the Regional Justice Center
Paul Jones sentenced to life with the
possibility of parole after serving more
than 24 years when he had the
opportunity to apologize for killing his
son he showed no remorse there is not a
date that close by I don't think my
groups Pia Coleman speaks in court as
her grandchild's killer appears
virtually from jail Paul Jones has
refused to show up in person after
pleading guilty to murder and child
abuse his son Aaron was just 13 when he
killed him and hid his body in 2017.
it's just not fair me and my family
don't have Aaron in nothing give back
Aaron suffered repeated abuse at the
hands of Jones he was placed with his
father by the child welfare system
despite Jones already being on probation
for child abuse according to an arrest
report Jones neglected bullied and beat
his son repeatedly while they lived in a
one-bedroom apartment with 10 kids
Aaron's family on his maternal side says
the child was bright loving and the
Heart and Soul of his family fear honors
so much damage has been done theirs not
enough therapy counseling and medication
in the world to fix this Vanessa Murphy
it's time for Aaron to get Justice 8
News Now